[Music]
i felt like i was just cast yesterday
and now the show's out and we're
promoting it and i'm here with all my
you know people and i haven't seen them
in so long such a huge celebration it
feels like a family reunion it's like a
dream i'm like still taking this in i
feel like if i look around too much i'm
gonna freak out
[Music]
i'm really excited for the world to meet
iman vilani and see her performance as
kamala khan it's absolutely the heart
and center of the show and i think
people are going to love her imam
villani she is kamala khan you know
she's the biggest marvel fan you can
imagine it's being myself on a larger
scale like i get to go to work and play
dress-up it's literally what i did when
i was a kid and so
yeah it's uh it's quite easy i just put
a lot of my real life into into kamala's
character and making her as authentic as
possible are you sure that we can keep
that on to know mine that's a lawsuit
great that'll make captain marvel in
court it won't be the first case in the
american judiciary to hug it out our
cast is so close and we're like best
friends and everything you see on screen
is how it is in real life and so
just that relationship and getting to
spend so much time with these incredible
people when i have scenes with iman and
rish
uh we just have so much fun i wish i had
more scenes with saga every time i'm
with him i just break and i start
laughing it's the camaraderie of the
cast i mean you know we all are best
friends
[Music]
i'm very excited for people finally
because we've been working on this for a
very long time finally get to meet not
just kamala but the entire cast in
particular her her family who from the
comics were such a great ensemble and
now have been brought to life in an
amazing way i wanted to lay her as much
as i could a strong woman matriarch of
her household and is loving and kind but
can throw down this is one family
pakistani immigrant family in america we
just segue and you know assimilate with
everybody else so beautifully so you'll
see customs you'll see religious
festivals the khan family is perfect
they really i want to be adopted by them
kamala khan is a teenage girl so she
experiences all of the same
boy trauma boys excuse me yeah
you're kind of on my shirt sorry
it's high school you know there's always
that that drama bit you know comrade
comes in and you know bruno sees him and
he's like who is this you know and uh i
don't know it'll be it'll be cool for
the fans to see and i think you know
a lot of teenagers will relate to it it
starts out as a story in jersey city and
then expands to the entire globe having
a show with this type of representation
in the mcu is is huge and people being
able to turn on disney plus and and see
somebody that looks just like them and
you know find a different character that
they relate to because i think we have
such a beautiful diverse group of
personalities you're not going to
believe what you're going to see marvel
superheroes are they're big they're
brawny they're the corporate giants etc
etc they're from other worlds this is
real world
and real world has heroes and you can be
a hero too just believe because marvel
will make you believe
[Applause]
you